the film opened this in Sundance and the
Edinburgh Fringe Festival if you can
tell us a little bit about the reaction
of the audience so David and I and Kelly
who will be here momentarily were in
Sundance along with other members of the
cast and crew and it was really a lovely
response by the audience we screened in
front of 1300 people and they stayed for
20 minutes right to the end of the Q&A
and they loved the performances and so
it was quite heartening and then in
Borough we opened the festival in front
of 3,000 of our friends there and that
was also a really lovely experience I
see mr. Denham here and I what I see is
Logan lucky it's funny seeing you
playing the role of Lois a wonderful
character with a very limited horizon
how did you feel playing that role
actually iterate thank you all for being
here seriously this is pretty cool
I felt I felt great about playing Louie
you know I liked playing characters who
you know are complicated in the sense
that he only sees sort of one version of
his wife he doesn't really see who she
you know is other than kind of his needs
of who she is and you know as artists I
believe it's our job to try to
illuminate the human condition and I
felt like I know a lot of people who
have who you know have relationships
like this that aren't as evolved is we
would all like them to be sometimes and
you know mark and I talked quite a bit
about trying to not just be one one
sided with this guy to try to to try to
show a little bit of humanity of his you
know love for his wife and appreciation
for her but just a lack of knowledge
about who she is and and you know part
of that too is she's coming into her own
of like you know
I've never seen a coming-of-age story
for a woman in her 40s that I can
remember and I thought was really cool
when I read the script I thought that
was so unique and and I loved the idea
of telling that story I loved the idea
of working with Kelly Macdonald who's an
amazing actress as you all know and her
fond Khan as well although I didn't get
to work with him we just had lunches
together but he's amazing as well so you
know when it came across from my agent I
was like a hundred percent I mean you
know is amazing and can you tell us a
little bit about the origin of the
project a mr. Joe how do you came to it
well I got it as a screenplay I didn't
we didn't develop it internally it was
developed in another production company
and then they send it to me knowing I
was looking for a film to direct it was
based on an argentinian film from 2010
by natalia Smirnoff natalia came to the
set and I think she likes this
adaptation very well but I intentionally
didn't want to watch her film I had
never seen it because I wanted to bring
my own interpretation to the screenplay
and so I read it and like David I was
taking with the writing taking with the
subject matter it's so rare and as soon
as I read and I said this is a story I
have to tell and would the filmmaker or
environment
What did he say but there were there are
interesting changes and challenges in
this adaptation the film played at
Berlin an argent and French production
first feature film directed by Natalya
Smirnoff who's a disciple of sorts of
Lucrecia Martel so it's a minimally
story and implied there is a critique of
the the behaviour of the Argentine
middle class there are a change of
setting here there's interesting changes
so how aware were you of those I wasn't
aware cuz I didn't read the original
screenplay didn't watch the original
movie until I completely finished this
movie as I then watched it of course and
in her version
Agnes goes back to her husband
in the end as you undoubtedly know and
there are a number of other changes I
think the whole sort of Easter sort of
symbolism I think is more heavily
emphasized in the Argentinian version
but orange wrote a version for it for
today and for America I just want to add
to that like you know scripts evolve and
change as you film them and there was a
version of this when they were together
at the end and as we were filming it I
Mark had a lot of conversations about
this and I just kept saying I just don't
know if you earn this that you want them
to be together because of the way our
the way our story is unfolding that like
you kind of have to maybe consider
another alternative and he was totally
open to it and was like it's possible
you know we're gonna keep going down
this road and sure enough I didn't know
how the movie ended til I saw it in
Sundance and I was like that's how this
movie should end what's interesting
about your journey is that it's an
interior journey a journey world there
are not that many landmarks that would
say that you you can look at them and
say well this is you know a big event
that happened so how did you construct
that character made of silence of looks
of ways of you know shopping of putting
the puzzles together how did you build
your character well I
luckily don't have to do that I'm
writers do that for me and I am i what i
loved about Agnes was that she's you
know she's surrounded by her family but
she's very sort of she's quite a lonely
person and her interior world starts
bubbling up to the surface I think and
I'm and I loved the way in the script
that these quiet moments she got to know
because the people around her to really
know her so the audience gets to know
her on her own it seems unbelievable
that in the 21st century 2018 someone
would not like a cellphone like the
iPhone that she had never been to New
York being half an hour
by train it led me to think that in many
ways what mister thought up here is
dealing with is like a fairy tale it's
an insight a timeless entire into human
behavior in this case the question that
you seem to be asking yourself which is
can I change my life here and now so she
doesn't go off into an adventure in any
way so she is figuring still out in that
last train to Montreal what she's going
to do that's why the film works
beautifully at the end because he it's
the question is being asked how much can
I change
yeah and thing that I loved about it is
like her life isn't being defined by a
romantic relationship or being solved
her problems aren't solved by a romantic
romantic relationship and it sort of
reminded me slightly of I did an
animated movie called brave and M she's
a Disney princess I played a Disney
princess but she's I think the only one
that doesn't sir if a man doesn't come
to her rescue and you know it's about
like married are very much in brave just
as you know she's fighting her own
battles and living her own life and and
in a way I saw a sort of a correlation
between two women and what about the the
playing the with the puzzles how did
that regress it looks quite convincing
that she's fast and efficient and she is
fast and efficient and it was
interesting because your farm was not
fast and efficient and really had no
interest in being fast and efficient and
Kelly I think took to it so you know
when the air farm was puzzling you know
they both the performances I think are
amazing so but Kelly's took I think just
took a shine to doing - doing the the
puzzles and there was always a puzzle
off the set of a thousand-piece puzzle
and after scenes she'd go over and start
putting pieces in and every all the
members of the crew would go over and
start putting pieces in everyone but got
really really involved in puzzling there
was it was we were filming and
the puzzle competition that was the
thing that really set us on the track to
doing puzzles daily at work um because
there was just tons of puzzles
everywhere and we started there was all
day on this it was all these tables of
different puzzles so we got we call into
there was me and there was a core group
of puzzlers and and we after that we
start we were filming in Manhattan and
not because we you know we completed a
number of puzzles well that scene in
syndra station could not have been very
easy to shoot which one in Central
Station when she gets there for the
first time yeah that was really
interesting Grand Central is interesting
because there were hundreds of people
right behind us and if they listened to
us it was weird yeah I would say get
back and they'd all get back and that's
how we knew they were from New York and
you know and and so there was this whole
crowd watching because everybody wants
to watch a movie being made but it
actually was pretty easy they they were
fairly yeah they listened I was gonna
kiss it like work and when you're
filming on in the public domain you're
not really allowed a lot at the time you
can ask people kindly to sort of stand
back or two but really you can't stop
anyone if they're determined there's no
sort of there's no law against it and
Grand Central was a piece of cake
compared to I just did some filming in
Scotland in Edinburgh on a street and it
was a totally you would think because
everybody uses the you know it's like
Grand Central Station and your sort of
thing but I mean I'm the main street in
Edinburgh was much worse to film in
earnest so on behalf of the Academy
thank you very much for being